[Music]
if it's like yo here's the sword million
dollars we'll do it no if it's like yo
you're in the wilderness you only got a
sword or die it's dead what if you're
like in the Colosseum and there's a
crowd
then I'm forced to do it then I'm gonna
kill it and I'll start making some
Reflections I distract this stupid thing
oh my God
Marty what I'm gonna do is get in a full
nelson all right Full Nelson grounded
pound if it lets me sink that [__]
hotel
oh I love that it Taps it starts to
happen
and no matter what at the end when I
kill it Joe Rogan's gonna come over and
[__] interview everybody
how did you feel to get your ass beat by
his overweight kid
you get